comme chaque année l'organisation
météorologique mondiale vient de publier
son nouveau rapport sur les gaz à effet
de serre dans le monde et il montre
hélas comme chaque année que les
émissions de co2 de dioxyde de carbone
continue d'augmenter et elle augmente au
rythme de 0 5% un petit peu +0 6%
une molécule sur 2450 pour être précis
une sur 2500 c'est du co2 alors il n'y a
pas de danger pour l'homme directement
gaz inerte si on le respire c'est pas
grave en revanche ça a un effet sur le
réchauffement climatique
parce que ça piège les rayons du soleil
et ça augmente la température
voilà ça c'est pas une très très bonne
nouvelle d'autant plus que les deux
autres gaz à effet de serre et en
particulier le méthane qui est 40 fois
plus qu'un effet 40 fois plus grand que
le co2 sur le réchauffement climatique
augmente encore plus vite car c'est une
évolution qui est très très rapide et on
n'avait pas eu donc c'est en gros 1
depuis le début de l'ère industrielle en
ccd émissions liées aux combustibles
fossiles donc le charbon et puis après
le pétrole le gaz naturel
voilà donc ça ça va vraiment très très
vite et il faut remonter à 3 5 millions
d'années pour avoir une concentration de
co2 dans l'atmosphère qui est
équivalente et
à l'époque la température était environ
2 à 3 degrés supérieure à celle qui est
aujourd'hui et le niveau des mers
étaient dix à vingt mètres plus haut
voilà mais c'était une profession qui
est différente celle qu'on connaît là
depuis le début de l'ère préindustrielle